sending a child off to college can be
tough especially if it's your only or
last child living at home so what can
you do to prepare yourself for those
changes here to talk about empty nest
syndrome and how to prepare for it is
psychiatrist timothy yeider with nevada
mental health dr eider thanks for being
here today thanks for having me kendall
it is tough when you have a child for 18
years and suddenly boom they're an adult
they're gone and especially if it's the
only child or the last one that you're
sending off what is empty nest syndrome
so it is exactly what you're just
describing is when there's a general
sense of reduction in the number of
people in the household but very
particularly when the last kid has left
the home and there's now this large
dynamic shift in the home because where
there used to be three people now
there's only two and that's just a huge
shift for people yeah and so what is the
emotional impact for parents
the the two largest things we tend to
see is when you have a parent who's been
a full-time parent right their whole
daily routine is around taking care of
their kid making sure their needs are
met and that routine is now disrupted
what do they do with their time the
other aspect is when that kid may have
served as a buffer in kind of a
contentious relationship where there may
have been some problems but it's easier
to focus on the kid rather than the
problem and now that buffer's gone
reality sets in right now you can focus
on each other it can be intense so what
can be done to mitigate some of those
things so the for the first group you're
going to look at finding new purpose new
meaning right we do great and feel great
when we're positively contributing to
our community and our society so find
new purpose find new ways to be involved
for the other set if you're noticing hey
now that buffer is gone there's those
really awkward nights the silences maybe
there's some relationship issues get
counseling a little bit of counseling
can go a long way to help adjust to that
period and save yourselves a lot of
headache in the long run and also you
don't want to inadvertently create
anxiety for the child you're sending
away
and have them worried about you right i
mean that's that's the we see kids come
into our practice all the time with that
where they've gone off to college and
they come home on break and hey mom mom
and dad are my parents aren't really the
same what's going on and then they get a
divorce and now that kid's thinking what
did i do how did this impact like what
did i do to this situation so then they
internalize that and so it can impact
the whole family counseling is always
good and some people are resistant to it
but i think the any stigma attached to
it seems to be diminishing it it has in
the last few years so many more people
have been open about
taking care of themselves including
mental health and so when when public
figures talk out about the services
they've had it really helps the rest of
us normalize the experience because i
can guarantee you everybody's had
something at some point that they've
needed help your clinic is particularly
busy uh in the wake of the pandemic yeah
that's the other big shifts right you
you throw everyone together in a small
space for large periods of time kids
aren't going to school they're home
parents are working from there again
that was a huge shift that no one saw
coming which created a lot of issues and
thankfully a lot of folks have reached
out for help well we appreciate you
being here today dr yider thanks so much
good to be here thank you for having me
all right rocky thank you